This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We are currently just two days away from the start of the 2024 Summer Olympics in Paris. And if you couldn't already tell from the TV commercials, the branded soda cans, and the Emily in Paris SponCon, the Olympics are once again everywhere. So in the Olympic spirit, we are bringing you four stories about the games and all their international theatrical glory. Starting with one from 99% invisible supervising producer,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。距离 2024 年巴黎夏季奥运会开幕目前仅剩两天。如果你还没从电视广告、品牌汽水罐以及《艾米丽在巴黎》的赞助内容中看出来的话，奥运会又一次无处不在了。因此，本着奥运精神，我们将为你带来四个关于奥运会及其所有国际盛况的故事。首先由 99% invisible 的总制片人，
Christopher Johnson. Hello, Christopher Johnson. What do you have for me today? Hello, Roman Mars. So this summer, for the first time ever, there'll be Olympic levellevel breakdancing. It's officially called breaking, and it's the first ever so-called dance sport
克里斯托弗·约翰逊带来。你好，克里斯托弗·约翰逊。今天你给我准备了什么？你好，罗曼·马斯。今年夏天，奥运赛场上将首次出现霹雳舞。它的官方名称是 Breaking（布雷金），这是奥运会历史上首次出现的所谓舞蹈体育项目。
to happen in summer Olympics history. Wow, I did not know that. That's very exciting. I agree. I support all things breakdancing, especially because I'm a hip-hop head. But breaking is not like running or swimming or throwing stuff.
哇，我以前真不知道。这太让人兴奋了。我同意。我支持所有与霹雳舞有关的事物，尤其是因为我是一个嘻哈迷。但霹雳舞不像跑步、游泳或扔东西。
It's not your typical Olympic sport. And this got me thinking, as unusual as Olympic breakdancing might seem, it cannot be the oddest event to ever be in the Games. And I was right. BOWEN Okay. And I was right. Okay, so tell me more. Okay, so first of all, I need you to know
它不是你眼中的典型奥运项目。这让我不禁思考，尽管奥运霹雳舞看起来很不寻常，但它绝对不可能是奥运史上最奇怪的项目。我猜得没错。BOWEN 好吧。我猜得没错。好吧，快跟我多讲讲。好的，首先，我需要你知道的是，
that many of the weirdest Olympic sports in history came into being way back before the Olympics were considered the pinnacle of professional athletics. Those earliest games were actually meant for amateurs. The modern games were started in 1896 by this French aristocrat named Pierre de Coubertin. This guy's life is a whole story in itself. You should look him up. But basically, the Olympics were his dream.
历史上许多最奇特的奥运项目诞生于奥运会尚未被视为职业田径运动巅峰的时期。最早的奥运会其实是为业余爱好者准备的。现代奥运会于 1896 年由一位名叫皮埃尔·德·顾拜旦的法国贵族发起。这家伙的一生本身就是一个传奇故事。你应该去查查他。但基本上，奥运会是他的梦想。
He pitched it in lectures all over France, like, let's all get together and play sports and then hand out medals and trophies. And these sports were definitely not for professional athletes. These were for, like, average amateurs. Exactly. These were mostly amateurs. And when the Olympics began, the spirit of the games
他在法国各地到处演讲来推广这个想法，比如，让我们聚在一起搞体育运动，然后颁发奖牌和奖杯。这些运动绝对不是为职业运动员准备的。这些是为普通业余爱好者准备的。没错。这些大多是业余爱好者。当奥运会开始时，奥运精神
was hardcore amateurism. So at that point, the one-offs and the crazies and all sorts of folks just show up. I talked to David Goldblatt, who wrote a book called The Games, a global history of the Olympics. And he told me just how casual the earliest Olympic games were.
就是彻底的业余主义。所以在那个时候，奇葩项目、疯狂运动以及各种各样的人都会出现。我采访了戴维·戈德布拉特，他写过一本名为《运动：奥运会的全球历史》的书。他告诉我最早的奥运会有多随性。
I mean, in 1896, the Athens games, the first games, the guys that won the pistol competition are two brothers from Harvard and they're on holiday. So these guys just rolled up to the Olympics pistol event. Like, Hey y'all, we have guns. We can shoot. They just showed up. They had their pistols with them, of course, you know, as everybody does when they travel in the 19th century, and they took part.
我是说，在 1896 年的雅典奥运会上，即第一届奥运会上，赢得手枪射击比赛的是来自哈佛的两个兄弟，他们当时正在度假。所以这两个家伙就这样大摇大摆地参加了奥运会的手枪射击项目。就像是，嘿，各位，我们有枪。我们会射击。他们就这么出现了。他们随身带着手枪，当然啦，就像 19th 世纪人们旅行时那样，然后他们就参赛了。
Okay, so in the first modern Olympics, people could just like walk on off the street and they could participate. Exactly. That's outstanding. And the fact that the Olympics were new and experimental and not at all about being a pro, that opened the door to all sorts of sports being in those early games. For example, in the second ever modern Olympic games,
好吧，所以在现代第一届奥运会上，人们可以像从街上随便走进来一样参赛。没错。这太出色了。奥运会是崭新的、实验性的，完全不是为了成为职业运动员，这一事实为各种各样的运动进入早期的奥运会打开了大门。例如，在第二届现代奥运会上，
one of the events was firefighting. Oh my goodness, how did that work? So they lit a house on fire and you had to put that out, and then you had to do a fake rescue. Wow. The 1900 games also had this aquatics event where you'd go under boats and then over boats and then under some more boats.
其中一个项目是消防。哦天哪，那是怎么运作的？所以他们点燃了一栋房子，你必须把它扑灭，然后你还得进行一次假救援。哇。1900 年的奥运会还有一个水上项目，你需要从船底穿过，然后从船上翻过去，接着再穿过更多的船。
Obstacle swimming is a tremendous event and you had swimmers diving off boats that had been moored on the river and they would swim 20 meters and then they would have to either go under a second set of boats and come out the other side, or sometimes they had to clamber into the boat and then dive off back into the river. And this is all happening on the Seine. Lord knows what
障碍游泳是一个了不起的项目，游泳运动员从停在河上的船上跳水，他们游 20 米，然后必须从第二组船下方穿过并从另一边出来，或者有时他们必须爬上船，然后再跳回河里。而这一切都发生在塞纳河上。鬼知道
the condition of the water was. Other events from the 1900 games include hot air balloon racing and croquet and cannon shooting. Can you imagine cannon shooting in the Olympics? So if I'm hearing you right, the 1900 games specifically was the one with so many great unusual events. Yes. But check this out. One reason these Olympics have so many random events, may very well be because the 1900
当时的水质是什么样。1900 年奥运会的其他项目还包括热气球比赛、槌球和射击大炮。你能想象奥运会上有射击大炮吗？所以如果我没听错的话，1900 年的奥运会特别有很多精彩的不寻常项目。是的。但你看这个。这些奥运会有这么多随机项目的一个原因，很可能是因为 1900 年的
games weren't really actually, factually, officially recognized as the Olympics. At least not until like 80 years later. Okay, so what do you mean by that? So in 1900, the Olympics was just in its second year, and it wasn't its own established standalone thing yet. So they kind of just glommed on to the World's Fair, which was also happening in Paris at the same time. And the World's Fair people really didn't know what the hell the Olympics even were.
奥运会实际上并没有真正、事实、官方上被认可为奥运会。至少直到大约 80 年以后才被认可。好吧，你这是什么意思？所以在那时 1900 年，奥运会才刚刚举办到第二年，它还不是一个独立且成熟的正式活动。所以他们有点像是依附于当时也在巴黎同时举办的世界博览会。而世博会的人根本不知道奥运会到底是什么鬼东西。
Some folks thought it was this weird neo-Hellenic cult. Nobody really knew that the Olympics were going on. There were no posters with Olympic insignia around. The press referred to it as the International Games, or, you know, they didn't quite know what to do with it. The 1900 Games were also an outlier in much of Olympic history, because instead of lasting just two weeks, those games lasted five whole months.
有些人以为这是一个奇怪的新希腊教派。没有人真正知道奥运会正在进行。周围没有带有奥运会标志的海报。媒体称之为国际运动会，或者，你知道的，他们不知道该拿它怎么办。1900 年的奥运会在奥运历史上也是一个特例，因为这些比赛没有持续短短两周，而是整整持续了五个月。
And they had more than double the events that we have today. And in the end, the IOC had to go back 80 years later and decide which of those weirdo events were even gonna count in the Olympic records. It was only in the 1980s that actually a definitive list of who won what, what events were Olympic and which weren't were drawn up by the IOC. And one event that most definitely was not considered
而且它们的比赛项目数量是我们今天的两倍多。最后，国际奥委会不得不在此后的 80 年里回溯过去，决定那些奇葩项目里到底有哪些能够计入奥运会纪录。直到 20 世纪 80 年代，国际奥委会才真正拟定了一份权威名单，列出谁赢得了什么、哪些项目是奥运项目而哪些不是。其中一个绝对不被认为是的项目是
Olympic was the firefighters. Yeah, huge mistake. Huge mistake. Totally agree. Rest in peace, firefighting in the Olympics. But listen, listen. The fun Olympic sports didn't end with 1900. And in fact, one of those sports put the United States at the center of an Olympic scandal. And that sport was tug of war. Tug of war is an absolutely fantastic sport.
奥运消防。是的，巨大的错误。巨大的错误。完全同意。愿奥运消防安息吧。但是听着，听着。有趣的奥运项目并没有在 1900 年结束。事实上，其中一项运动将美国推向了一场奥运丑闻的中心。这项运动就是拔河。拔河绝对是一项极其精彩的运动。
I can't believe actually that we don't still have it in the Olympics. So you might think of tug of war as something you did as part of field day when you were growing up, like right after the sack races and before running with an egg on a spoon. But in the early 1900s, tuguck of War, Roman Mars, was hot. So hot, it was in five summer games. I mean, this also strikes me as super fun to watch. You got all these gigantic Andre the Giant,
我甚至不敢相信我们至今仍未将它保留在奥运会中。所以你可能会认为拔河就像是你小时候在运动会上做的一样，就像在赛麻袋之后、用勺子运鸡蛋跑步之前那样。但在 20 世纪初，罗曼·马斯，拔河可是相当热门。火热到它连续出现在五届夏季奥运会上。我的意思是，这也让我觉得看这个超级有趣。你拥有所有这些庞大的安德烈巨星般的人物，
with the singlet on, you're like Weshelmania 3 style, you know, like, and just pulling on things. You just get your biggest dudes in the whole country. Exactly, it is everything that you're picturing. It's like, you know, between five and eight guys, the numbers changed over time on each side, pulling for their lives. It's basic, it's straightforward, it's primal. But for such a simple sport, Olympic tug of war got a little spicy, Roman.
穿着单衣，就像是摔角狂热 3 的风格，你知道的，然后就在拉扯各种东西。你只需要全国家块头最大的人就行了。没错，它就是你脑海中想象的那样。就像是，你知道的，五到八个人，随着时间推移，每边的人数有所变化，在拼死拔河。它很基础，很直观，很原始。但对于这样一项简单的运动来说，奥运拔河变得有点火药味了，罗曼。
Lots of little scandals along the way. The 1908 games in London are probably the best example of that. You've got a British team and an American team contesting. The Americans is basically a scratch team. It's like the wrestlers and the heavy guys from the field events and they're put together. And they're going against the Brits who have a legit tug of war team. They're all members of the Liverpool city police and they're hella strong. They've been training a lot.
一路走来有很多小丑闻。1908 年的伦敦奥运会大概就是最好的例子。有一支英国队和一支美国队在竞争。美国队基本上是一支拼凑的队伍。就像是由摔跤手和来自田径项目的壮汉们临时组合在一起。他们要对阵拥有正规拔河队伍的英国人。他们都是利物浦市警察局的成员，而且力大无穷。他们训练有素。
Tug of war is what they do. But the real edge that the Brits have got is that these guys show up in their work boots and they've got steel-capped heels. And you can imagine, given how tug of war works, that is giving you a real edge over a bunch of guys who are wearing their track shoes. That is the American side.
拔河就是他们的日常。但英国人真正的优势在于，这些家伙穿着工装靴来，脚后跟带有钢帽。你可以想象，考虑到拔河的运作方式，这绝对比穿田径鞋的一群人更有优势。这就是美国队的情况。
They're at this huge disadvantage. The Liverpool team absolutely crushed them. The Americans, of course, incensed, saying, this can't possibly be in the rules. The Americans contested. They were overruled. The Brits won. And the Americans apparently left in a huff. What I love about this moment is that the American sports press, which is just kind of finding its hyperbolic voice at this moment in history, writes about the event and the New York
他们处于巨大的劣势。利物浦队彻底击败了他们。美国人当然大发雷霆，说这绝对不可能符合规则。美国人提出了抗议。他们被驳回了。英国人赢了。美国人显然气冲冲地离开了。我喜欢这个时刻的一点是，当时美国体育界正处于历史上的夸张语调寻找期，他们对这一事件进行了报道，《纽约
Evening Post said of the City of Liverpool police boots, they had inch thick soles and were heavier than those worn in the English Navy, while the New York Evening World thought the Boots were as big as North River ferryboats. By the way, at that same Olympics, another British tug-of-war team, the City of London police team, they later challenged the Americans to a match in just their socks. And the Americans said, no thanks. LAUGHS
晚报》对利物浦市警察的靴子评论道，它们的鞋底有一英寸厚，比英国海军穿的靴子还要重，而《纽约晚报世界》则认为这些靴子和北河渡轮一样大。顺便说一句，在那届奥运会上，另一支英国拔河队伍——伦敦市警察局队，后来向美国人发起挑战，要求只穿袜子进行一场比赛。美国人则说，不用了，谢谢。笑声
Okay, so they probably knew what was up. Right, right. You see how it is there. Now, obviously, sadly, we no longer have Olympic level tug of war. Again, criminal shame. Totally, right? We also don't have obstacle swimming or cannon shooting. Come on.
好吧，所以他们可能心里有数。对，对。你看那边的情况就是这样。现在，很显然，遗憾的是，我们再也没有奥运级别的拔河了。再次说明，这真是一个犯罪般的遗憾。完全同意，对吧？我们也没有障碍游泳或射击大炮。拜托。
Most of them disappeared pretty quickly once the Olympics became the professionalized event that we know it to be today. But that doesn't mean that we lost all interesting sports because there's a whole other category known as demonstration sports. I think I have some idea what those are but could you describe demonstration sports to me? Sure. So those are essentially sports from specific regions in the world that aren't meant to be official sports just yet. They're kind of just played for show and to promote the international spirit of the
一旦奥运会变成了我们今天所知的职业化赛事，它们大多数很快就消失了。但这并不意味着我们失去了所有有趣的运动，因为还有另一个完全不同的类别，被称为表演项目。我想我大致知道那些是什么，不过你能向我描述一下表演项目吗？当然。这些本质上是世界上特定地区的运动，暂时还不打算成为正式的体育项目。它们有点像是纯粹为了展示以及弘扬国际精神而进行的
games. They're chosen by the host. And usually it's an opportunity to showcase a sport that is not globally particularly well-known, but which is important to that nation. So for example, there's this sport called Glima, which is basically Viking wrestling. That was a demo sport in 1912. Later you get Swedish gymnastics, which I didn't know existed. There's Korfball, which shined for a couple years in the 1920s. But some events
比赛。它们由主办方挑选。通常这是一个展示某种在全球范围内并不特别知名、但对该国很重要的运动的机会。例如，有一项名为 Glima（格利马）的运动，基本上就是维京摔跤。那是 1912 年的一个表演项目。后来你有了瑞典体操，我以前都不知道它存在。还有合球（Korfball），它在 20 世纪 20 年代闪耀了几年。但有些项目
do eventually become permanent fixtures of the Olympics. So in 1964, for example, judo became a demonstration sport. And in the case of judo, and this is also true of taekwondo, first introduced as a demonstration sport by the South Koreans at the 1988 Seoul Olympics, they then go on to be permanent Olympic sports. I mean, that is nice that they can introduce new things and then have them be adopted as more and more of the world takes them on as no longer regional sports. That's great. I mean, do we have any cool demo sports this year that you're aware of? Sadly, we do not.
最终确实成为了奥运会的永久固定项目。比如在 1964 年，柔道成为了表演项目。而在柔道以及跆拳道的例子中——跆拳道最早是由韩国人在 1988 年汉城奥运会上作为表演项目引入的——它们后来都成为了永久的奥运项目。我的意思是，能够引入新事物，然后随着世界上越来越多的人将它们作为不再是区域性的运动来接受，从而被采纳，这真的很棒。太棒了。我的意思是，今年有什么你知道的酷炫表演项目吗？遗憾的是，我们没有。
The last demo games included in the Olympics were actually way back in 1992, which had several games, including roller hockey. Well, if we don't get any demo sports, at least we have breaking to look forward to. That's going to be exciting. Well, thank you so much for this, Christopher. I had fun.
奥运会中包含的最后一届表演项目实际上要追溯到 1992 年，当时有几个项目，包括轮滑冰球。好吧，如果我们没有任何表演项目，至少我们还有霹雳舞值得期待。那将会很令人兴奋。好的，非常感谢你带来这些，克里斯托弗。我玩得很开心。
Same here, Roman Mars. You're welcome. ["The Star-Spangled Banner"] When a city hosts the Olympics, they have to construct a ton of new buildings, like an entire village to house the athletes, and a track and field stadium, and a specialty venue for bicycle races, and the list can get very long. Sometimes those structures end up being a fixture of civic life for years to come, like
我也是，罗曼·马斯。不客气。["星条旗永不落"]当一个城市主办奥运会时，他们必须建造大量的新建筑，比如供运动员居住的整个村庄、一个田径体育场、一个专用于自行车比赛的场馆，而这个清单可以拉得很长。有时，这些建筑最终会成为多年后市民生活的一部分，比如
the London Stadium, which now hosts soccer games, or the Atlanta Athletes Village, which has been converted into student housing. But there are also venues that become white elephants, booming over the skyline and offering grim reminders of the high cost of two weeks of fun, such as the case in Montreal, Canada, host of the 1976 Summer Olympics. Here's producer Chris Berube. The Montreal Olympics were the brainchild of Jean Drapeau. And I think it's fair to say when it comes to big city mayors, they don't make them like Drapeau anymore.
现在举办足球比赛的伦敦碗，或是已被改建为学生公寓的亚特兰大运动员村。但也有一些场馆变成了白象工程，耸立在地平线上，残酷地提醒人们两周狂欢的高昂代价，例如 1976 年夏季奥运会主办地加拿大蒙特利尔的情况。这是制片人克里斯·贝鲁布。蒙特利尔奥运会是让·德拉波的 brainchild（心血结晶）。我认为公平地说，说到大城市市长，他们现在已经不制作像德拉波这样的人了。
Jean Drapeau served as mayor twice between 1954 and 1986. He wasn't very intimidating. He was kind of diminutive, always had these big square glasses and this of-the-time mustache. But during his hotly debated 29 years in office, Jean Drapeau had big ambitions. He used to drive around Montreal in a limousine, blasting arias by Richard Wagner and stopping to talk with his constituents and admire some of the works he had commissioned. Even though Toronto overtook Montreal as Canada's biggest city in the 70s, Drapeau insisted that his town would always be the greatest. Let Toronto become Milan, Drapeau once said, because Montreal will always be Rome.
让·德拉波在 1954 年到 1986 年间两度担任市长。他并不是那种很有压迫感的人。他有点矮小，总是戴着大方框眼镜，留着那个时代的胡子。但在他备受争议的 29 年任期内，让·德拉波有着宏大的抱负。他经常开着豪华轿车在蒙特利尔转悠，放着理查德·瓦格纳的咏叹调，并停下来和选民交谈，欣赏他委托创作的一些作品。尽管多伦多在 70 年代超过蒙特利尔成为加拿大最大的城市，但德拉波坚称他的城市永远是最伟大的。德拉波曾说过：“让多伦多成为米兰吧，因为蒙特利尔永远是罗马。”
And during his early years as mayor, the city did go on quite a hot streak. Drapeau managed to rustle up a subway system, a major league baseball team, a World's Fair, and in a masterstroke, the Summer Olympics of 1976, somehow beating out both Moscow and Los Angeles for the honor. For Drapeau, the Olympics would cement Montreal as Canada's greatest metropolis. But he faced some pointed questions. Like, how exactly are we supposed to afford all of this? Drapot was unfazed by the criticism.
在他担任市长初期，这座城市确实经历了一段非常火热的时期。德拉波成功弄来了一个地铁系统、一支美国职棒大联盟球队、一个世界博览会，并在神来之笔下赢得了 1976 年的夏季奥运会，在荣誉之争中击败了莫斯科和洛杉矶。对德拉波来说，奥运会将巩固蒙特利尔作为加拿大最伟大都会的地位。但他面临着一些尖锐的质问。比如，我们到底该如何承担这一切的费用？德拉波对这些批评不以为然。
He famously promised voters, the Olympic Games could no more run a deficit than a man could have a baby. And if you're thinking, hey, that's kind of a weird thing to say, I wonder if those words would come back to haunt him in some way. Perhaps you've guessed the outcome here, but those words would 100% come back to haunt him. Of the proposed $120 million budget for the Olympics, more than half was reserved just for constructing Olympic Stadium.
他向选民们作出了著名的承诺，奥运会产生赤字的几率就像男人能生孩子一样。如果你在想，嘿，这话听起来有点怪，我很好奇这些话会不会在某种程度上反过来缠上他。也许你已经猜到了结果，但这些话百分之百地反过来缠上了他。在提议的 1.2 亿美元奥运预算中，超过一半仅用于建设奥林匹克体育场。
It was designed to have this unique donut shape, giving it the nickname the Big O. And it promised to be state-of-the-art, with a retractable roof that would kind of look like a big white tortoise shell. The closable roof was a novelty at the time, and the idea was that sports could be played there after the games, during Montreal's brutal winters. But the most distinct feature of the Olympic Stadium would be a 540-foot tower that would arch over the field at a dramatic 45-degree slant. A tower was an unusual thing to add to a stadium, but Drapeau was insistent.
它的设计呈独特的甜甜圈形状，因此获得了“大O”（Big O）的绰号。它承诺将是最先进的，带有可伸缩的屋顶，看起来有点像一个巨大的白色乌龟壳。可关闭的屋顶在当时是个新奇事物，其想法是奥运会结束后，在蒙特利尔严酷的冬天里，仍然可以在那里进行体育运动。但奥林匹克体育场最显著的特征将是一座 540 英尺高的塔楼，它以戏剧性的 45 度倾斜角拱卫在球场上方。在体育场里加一座塔是一个不寻常的举动，但德拉波坚持不懈。
He wanted it to be like the Eiffel Tower, an icon that everybody conjured when they heard the name Montreal. But reviews were mixed. Years later, a columnist for the Montreal Gazette, Jack Todd, would call the stadium design space-aged fascist. When construction began on the Big O,
他希望它就像埃菲尔铁塔一样，成为每个人听到蒙特利尔这个名字时脑海中浮现的标志。但大家的评价褒贬不一。多年后，《蒙特利尔宪报》的专栏作家杰克·托德将体育场的设计称为“太空时代的法西斯风格”。当“大O”开始施工时，
the problem started pretty much right away. Construction kicked off 18 months late, and then it got delayed again by a worker strike that wiped out most of 1975. That left just one year to finish the project before the thing was supposed to open. Against all odds, Drapo's Grand Olympic Stadium was finally finished right before the games. Well, sort of finished. The state of the art retractable roof, it wasn't ready. Neither was Drapo's big tower, not even close. Only the very bottom was completed.
问题几乎立刻就出现了。施工进度比计划晚了 18 个月，接着又因为一场抹去了 1975 年大部分时间的工人罢工而再次延误。这使得在场馆本该开幕之前，只剩下一年时间来完成这个项目。克服重重困难，德拉波宏伟的奥林匹克体育场终于在奥运会开幕前夕完工了。嗯，算是完工了。最先进的可伸缩屋顶还没准备好。德拉波的大塔也没有，差得远呢。只有最底部完工了。
So on opening day, the tower was still just a stump, with some wires poking out of the top. It just sat there, like this puny concrete tree trunk. Despite all this, the games, for the most part, went pretty well. People won medals, the city got some nice press, but when you talk to Montrealers about the 1976 Olympics, nobody leads with the athletes or the fanfare. They only want to talk about the hangover. At the time of the games, some estimates put the cost of the stadium at over $500 million,
所以在开幕当天，这座塔仍然只是个树桩，顶端戳着一些电线。它就那样立在那里，像一截瘦弱的混凝土树干。尽管如此，奥运会总体上还算顺利。人们赢得了奖牌，这座城市也获得了一些不错的媒体报道，但当你和蒙特利尔人谈论 1976 年奥运会时，没有人会首先提起运动员或盛况。他们只想谈论宿醉。在奥运会期间，一些估计将体育场的成本定在超过 5.0 亿美元，
just way over budget. But the worst was yet to come. After the Olympics, the stadium became the new home of the Montreal Expos baseball team, which was kind of perfect because the Expos had been playing in a makeshift ball field in a municipal park before that, and they needed the upgrade. But my god, the Big O was a horrible place to watch baseball. I remember how sound used to echo off the concrete walls
这完全超出了预算。但最糟糕的还在后头。奥运会结束后，这座体育场成为了蒙特利尔博览会棒球队的新主场，这简直完美，因为在此之前，博览会队一直在一个市级公园的临时球场里比赛，他们确实需要升级。但天哪，“大O”观看棒球比赛简直是个糟糕透顶的地方。我还记得声音是如何在混凝土墙壁
in the hideous yellow plastic seats. And the aesthetics were the least of their problems. The big dramatic tower, that was finished in 1977, but it was clearly something of a rush job. At one point years later, there was an explosion in the tower, and chunks of steel fell off during a game. Thankfully, nobody got hurt. But the biggest headache was the retractable roof.
和那些丑陋的黄色塑料座位间回荡的。而美学只是他们面临的最小问题。那座引人注目的巨塔直到 1977 年才完工，但它显然有点赶工的嫌疑。多年后的某一天，塔内发生了爆炸，比赛期间有钢块掉了下来。谢天谢地，没有人受伤。但最大的头疼问题是可伸缩屋顶。
That wasn't completed until 1987, a full 10 years overdue. And to put it bluntly, the roof was not very good at being a roof. It was made of Kevlar, and one time when it rained, drops pierced through the tarp, soaking everybody in the crowd. Then the roof was hit by a tornado in 1991, which tore a bunch of holes in it, and the same year, a support beam collapsed, and the team had to play the rest of their games on the road. Eventually, they gave up on the whole state of the art retractable thing and the roof, it just became a normal roof, but that didn't fix much. A couple of times snow built up over the winter and caused small cave-ins.
直到 1987 年它才完工，整整迟到了 10 年。直白地说，这个屋顶做屋顶真是不合格。它是由凯夫拉尔纤维制成的，有一次下雨时，雨滴透过防水布穿透进来，把人群中的每个人都淋湿了。接着屋顶在 1991 年遭到龙卷风袭击，上面撕裂了一堆洞，同年，一根支撑梁倒塌了，球队不得不把剩余的比赛都在客场进行。最终，他们放弃了整个最先进的可伸缩屋顶的想法，屋顶变成了一个普通的屋顶，但这并没有解决多少问题。冬天积雪堆积了几次，导致了小规模的坍塌。
Gosh, I cannot get into all of the calamities that happened with this roof. Bob Ojeda, a pitcher for the LA Dodgers, put it succinctly, this roof, even when the thing worked, it didn't work. The city finally paid off its Olympic debt in 2006, 30 years after the games. And while estimates vary, if you count up all the stadium shenanigans,
天哪，我简直无法列举这个屋顶发生的所有灾难。洛杉矶道奇队的投手鲍勃·奥赫达精辟地总结道：“这个屋顶，就算它能运作的时候，它也无法运作。”这座城市终于在 2006 年、奥运会结束 30 年后付清了奥运债务。虽然估计数字有所不同，但如果你把所有关于体育场的折腾都算上，
the final price tag for the Montreal Olympics was over $1.2 billion. Today, the stadium's not even home to the Montreal Expos. They left town in 2004, but the big O is still standing. According to the provincial government, it would just cost way too much to tear it down. So instead, they're going to spend hundreds of millions of dollars to make it better.
蒙特利尔奥运会的最终价格标签超过了 12.0 亿美元。今天，这座体育场甚至不再是蒙特利尔博览会队的主场了。他们在 2004 年离开了这座城市，但“大O”依然挺立着。据省政府称，拆除它的成本实在太高了。所以他们打算花数亿美元来对其进行修缮。
The culture minister says the city actually needs a major concert venue. Maybe Taylor Swift or Beyonce could play there since both of them skipped Montreal on their last world tour. So the leaning tower and the concrete ring, they aren't going anywhere. They remain this potent symbol,
文化部长表示，这座城市实际上需要一个大型音乐会场地。也许泰勒·斯威夫特或碧昂丝可以在那里表演，因为她们俩在上一次世界巡演中都跳过了蒙特利尔。所以倾斜的塔楼和混凝土环哪儿也不会去。它们依然是这个强有力的象征，
mocking everybody who thought this futuristic donut could ever be the Quebecois Coliseum. John Drapeau was wrong about a lot of things. About the Olympics paying for themselves, about who he hired to build the stadium, about how he would be remembered. But he was right about this. Nothing really looks like the Big O. And when I think of Montreal, I can't really imagine the city without it. There's really one day, one event, when an Olympic Stadium is on full display. And that event is the opening ceremony.
嘲笑着所有认为这个充满未来感的甜甜圈能成为魁北克竞技场的人。让·德拉波在很多事情上都错了。关于奥运会自负盈亏，关于他雇来建造体育场的建筑工人，关于他将被人们如何铭记。但他有一点没说错。没有什么东西看起来真的像“大O”。当我想到蒙特利尔时，我真的无法想象没有它的这座城市。确实有一天，有一个活动，奥林匹克体育场会得到最充分的展现。那个活动就是开幕式。
It is a high stakes moment where a lot can go right or very, very wrong. Here's 99PI supervising producer Vivian Ley with a story about the opening ceremony to change all opening ceremonies. Unfortunately, many animals were harmed in the making of this story. Yes. So, Roman, this pretty horrible thing happened during the Seoul Olympics in South Korea. And I will admit that when I first learned about this horrible thing, I did immediately think this is a 99PI story. Okay.
这是一个高风险的时刻，许多事情可能会进展顺利，也可能会非常、非常糟糕。这里是 99PI 的总制片人维维安·雷，她带来了一个旨在改变所有开幕式的开幕式的故事。不幸的是，在这个故事的制作过程中，许多动物受到了伤害。是的。所以，罗曼，在韩国首尔奥运会期间发生了一件相当可怕的事情。我承认，当我第一次得知这件可怕的事情时，我确实立刻觉得这是一个 99PI 的故事。好吧。
Well, now I'm nervous. Okay. But go for it. Okay, well now I'm nervous. Okay, but go for it. So just to set the scene, the year is 1988. It's a beautiful sunny day in Seoul. In the stands of Seoul Olympic Stadium is a sea of perms and aviator sunglasses. Hundreds of drummers and synchronized dancers just performed on the field. The athletes just finished marching out on the track for the Parade of Nations.
好吧，现在我开始紧张了。好吧，但尽管说吧。好吧，现在我开始紧张了，好吧，但请继续。为了设定场景，那一年是 1988 年。首尔迎来了美丽晴朗的一天。首尔奥林匹克体育场的看台上是一片烫发和飞行员太阳镜的海洋。数百名鼓手和齐舞舞者刚刚在场地上表演完毕。运动员们刚刚在跑道上完成了国家代表团入场式。
That was my favorite part. All the flags. Yes, all the flags, all the Germans in silly hats. The Olympic flag has just been raised to possibly the most dramatic music ever written. 2,400 doves of peace have just been released while five jets simultaneously sky-write the Olympic rings over the crowd. It was a scene which leads us all into the pivotal moment of the opening ceremony, which is the lighting of the Olympic flame. So the torch was just carried into the stadium by a 76-year-old Sun Ki-jung, who was actually
那是我的最爱。所有的旗帜。是的，所有的旗帜，所有戴着滑稽帽子的德国人。奥运会会旗刚刚伴随着可能是有史以来最戏剧性的音乐升起。2400 只和平鸽刚刚被放飞，同时五架喷气式飞机在人群上空用空中写字法同时画出奥运五环。这个场景将我们所有人引入了开幕式的关键时刻，那就是点燃奥林匹克圣火。火炬刚刚由 76 岁的孙基祯带入体育场，他实际上是
the first ethnic Korean to win an Olympic medal half a century earlier. And he's running the flame over to the Olympic Cauldron, which is this absolutely massive structure that looks maybe 100 feet tall. And so, you know, the torchbearers have to be raised slowly on this platform up to the cauldron to light the flame. And I am actually just gonna play you the video of what happened next so you can see it for yourself.
半个世纪前第一位赢得奥运会奖牌的朝鲜族人。他正把圣火跑向奥运火炬盆，这是一个绝对巨大的结构，看起来可能有一百英尺高。所以，你知道的，火炬手必须在这个平台上慢慢升起，靠近火炬盆来点燃圣火。我其实要播放接下来发生的事情的视频，这样你可以亲眼看看。
Okay. Okay, so they're being raised up to the platform on this little elevator, and they're about 10 feet away. And there's three torchbearers, and they're facing the crowd. They're not facing the cauldron, but the cauldron is full of birds. Like, there are birds everywhere.
好的。好吧，他们在这个小电梯上被升到平台上，他们距离大约有 10 英尺。有三名火炬手，他们面向人群。他们没有面向火炬盆，但火炬盆里全都是鸟。就像，到处都是鸟。
Some of them are flying, some of them are staying. And they're turning around. They're turning around and they're about to light and they have no idea what's going to happen. Oh my God. Oh, okay. The thing caught. Oh, some of them.
有些在飞，有些在呆着。他们转过身来了。他们转过身来准备点火，他们完全不知道会发生什么。天哪。哦，好吧。着火了。哦，有些。
Oh no. Oh no. There they go. Yeah. A few of them made it out. But several did not, you can really tell. Yeah. Oh my god.
噢不。噢不。它们飞走了。是的。其中几只逃出去了。但有好几只没有，你真的能看出来。是的。哦天哪。
Oh, the humanity. Oh, the humanity. But yeah, so of course I feel terrible for the doves. This is horrible to see. But I felt especially terrible for the torchbearers because what are they going to do, they're on this gigantic platform up in the sky. Yeah, and from the video, you can tell like,
人类啊，人类啊。但是，是的，所以我当然为鸽子感到难过。看到这一幕太可怕了。但我对火炬手感到特别难过，因为他们能怎么办呢，他们悬挂在天空中这个巨大的平台上。是的，从视频中你可以看出，
the doves from the edges had somewhat dispersed. But also, when you're in front of that many people, it is really hard to ad lib or to change it up a little bit when you're expected to do something extremely important. All they have in their hand is a lit torch. Like, what are you going to do? It's so unfortunate. I feel so bad for everybody involved. Yeah. You probably wouldn't know it from the video, but the Animal Handlers actually trained for a year. They were supposed to, you know, fly in these widening circles over the field and then disperse into five different directions. But a lot of them, I guess, landed on the Olympic cauldron.
边缘的鸽子已经在某种程度上散开了。而且，当你面对那么多人时，在被期望做一件极其重要的事情时，即兴发挥或稍微改变一下是很难的。他们手里只有一支点燃的火炬。拜托，你能做什么？这太不幸了。我为参与其中的每个人感到难过。是的。你可能从视频中看不出来，但动物驯养员其实训练了一年。他们本应该，你知道的，在场地上空盘旋成扩大的圆圈，然后向五个不同的方向散开。但我想，其中许多落在了奥林匹克火炬盆上。
Yeah, doing what doves do. They land on things. Exactly. They're just gonna, doves are gonna dove. But yeah, this scene in which a number of doves being consumed by the Olympic flame happened in front of tens of millions of people around the world. The other horrible part of this is that, hosting the Olympics was a really, really big deal for South Korea in general, because it had been a country that previously was ravaged by war and occupation and military dictatorship.
是的，做鸽子会做的事。它们落在各种东西上。没错。它们就是，鸽子就要做鸽子该做的事。但是，是的，许多鸽子被奥运圣火吞噬的这一幕，是在全世界数千万观众面前发生的。另一件可怕的事情是，对韩国总体而言，主办奥运会是一件非常非常大的事，因为该国以前曾饱受战争、占领和军事独裁的蹂躏。
So this was gonna be the moment where, they marked a new era for South Korea. Yeah, I remember, I was very aware of these Olympics. I was a alive and cognizant human being. And these were big games. They talked about this in the moment, that they were a big deal for Korea. And I can totally imagine, this is not
所以这将是一个时刻，他们标志着韩国的新时代。是的，我记得，我非常清楚这届奥运会。我是一个有知觉且活着的有生人类。这是一场盛大的比赛。他们在当时谈论过这一点，认为这对韩国来说是一件大事。我可以完全想象，这并不是
the best look for this international symbol piece getting torched in the Olympic cauldron. When you're trying to put your best foot forward, that's hard. But I mean, I do want to say that the Soul Games on the whole are actually really, really well received. Like this Olympics was seen as a really positive moment for the country's history. But the International Olympic Committee
这个国际象征在奥运火炬盆中被烧烤时的最佳形象。当你试图展现自己最好的一面时，这很难。但我的意思是，我确实想说，首尔奥运会总体上其实非常非常受欢迎。就像这届奥运会被视为该国历史上的一个非常积极的时刻。但国际奥委会
received so many complaints about the doves being burned alive on television that they actually decided to change the charter for the opening ceremony. And although it had been a part of the Olympics since 1920, they said like, no more live doves. We're done with the doves. And I actually, I do agree with this. I don't think live animals shouldn't be used
收到了关于鸽子在电视上被活活烧死的如此多的投诉，以至于他们实际上决定修改开幕式的章程。尽管自 1920 年以来它一直是奥运会的一部分，但他们表示，不，再也没有活鸽子了。我们和鸽子恩断义绝了。其实我确实同意这一点。我不认为活体动物不应该被使用
in these live situations because of what just happened. Yeah. I mean, it makes a ton of sense to me that they should just do away with it after some horrific incident because like nobody wants animals to be harmed. But given how the Olympics has all kinds of things that don't make any sense to me, that are just steeped in the tradition of the Olympics, I'm actually surprised that they removed this whole protocol from the opening ceremony just because of how symbolically powerful doves
在这些直播情况下，鉴于刚刚发生的事情。是的。我的意思是，在发生了一些可怕的事件后，他们应该废除这一做法，这对我来说完全说得通，因为没有人希望动物受到伤害。但鉴于奥运会有各种对我不合逻辑、只沉浸在奥运传统中的事情，我实际上很惊讶他们仅仅因为鸽子具有多大的象征力量，
are, but also just how stubborn they are about their own traditions. I mean, like, it just sort of blows my mind that they reacted so quickly. Well, funny that you say that because they never technically did remove the dove release from the opening ceremony. They just fully leaned into, you know, what you said, the symbolic nature of it, and then pivoted entirely to a, quote, symbolic dove release. Okay. What does a symbolic dove release look like? So the first Olympic games to do this was actually the 1994 Lillehammer Winter Olympics
但也因为他们对自身传统的顽固，而将这整个议程从开幕式中移除。我的意思是，他们反应如此之快，这简直让我大开眼界。好吧，真巧你说到这个，因为他们在技术上从未从开幕式中真正移除放飞鸽子的环节。他们只是完全融入了，你知道的，你所说的它的象征性质，然后完全转向了所谓的“象征性放飞鸽子”。好的。象征性的放飞鸽子是什么样子的？所以第一届这样做的奥运会实际上是 1994 年利勒哈默尔冬季奥运会，
and actually fun fact the dove release practice had not actually been as much a part of the winter games just because these games were usually hosted in like freezing cold cities that are inhospitable to live animals. That makes sense. But that year in 1992, they performed the first symbolic dove release by releasing white balloons. Oh, okay. Okay.
事实上，有趣的是，放飞鸽子的做法此前并不是冬季奥运会那么多的一部分，因为这些比赛通常在严寒的城市举办，对活体动物很不友好。这说得通。但在那一年，即 1992 年，他们通过释放白色气球进行了第一次象征性放飞鸽子。哦，好吧。好吧。
Those have their own problems, but I get it makes sense. But what have other cities done since then? So the next summer games, the 1996 Atlanta games, they had 100 children come running into the stadium with, you know, paper mache doves on sticks. So it looked like they were fluttering in the wind. The next couple games, the 2000 games in Sydney and the 2004 games in Athens,
那些有它们自己的问题，但我懂，这说得通。但从那以后其他城市都做了什么呢？所以下一届夏季奥运会，即 1996 年亚特兰大奥运会，他们让 100 名儿童拿着棍子上的纸扎鸽子跑进体育场。所以看起来它们在风中飞舞。接下来的几届奥运会，2000 年悉尼奥运会和 2004 年雅典奥运会，
they both featured projections of doves, which I think honestly is a little bit of a cop out. The 2008 Beijing games actually went pretty hard. Yeah, I mean the entire Beijing Olympics went pretty hard. Oh yeah, yeah. So like they had women dressed in white doing a dance and flapping their arms like bird wings as there was dove projections in the background and then that was followed by massive fireworks which also represented doves that were shooting out of the stadium.
它们的特点都是鸽子的投影，老实说，我认为这有点像是一种逃避。2008 年北京奥运会实际上做得相当硬核。是的，我的意思是整个北京奥运会都相当硬核。哦，是的，是的。所以，例如，他们让身穿白衣的妇女跳舞，并在背景有鸽子投影时像鸟翅膀一样拍打手臂，随后则是从体育场射出的代表鸽子的巨大烟花。
I think the 2012 London Olympics was my favorite interpretation. They had 75 white clad cyclists wearing LED wings circling the stadium. And I think it's my favorite because having people on bikes being the doves kind of makes absolutely no sense. That whole entire opening ceremony was just like a wacky fever daydream. And since then, you know, we've had the return of children this time they, you know, ran to the stadium wielding dove shaped kites. And then in the Tokyo Olympics, there were thousands of paper doves falling from the
我认为 2012 年伦敦奥运会是我最喜欢的演绎。他们有 75 名身穿白衣、佩戴 LED 翅膀的骑自行车者环绕体育场。我想这是我最喜欢的，因为让骑自行车的人来扮演鸽子完全没有任何意义。整个开幕式就像是一场古怪的发烧白日梦。自那以后，你知道的，我们迎来了儿童的回归，这一次他们，你知道的，挥舞着鸽子形状的风筝跑向体育场。然后在东京奥运会上，数千只纸鸽伴随着苏珊·博伊尔的音乐从
ceiling to the music of Susan Boyle. So that is how we have gotten past the live dove release in all of the ceremonies since then. You know, even though this has important symbolism, I'm kind of intrigued by the idea that each host country has to come up with this whole new form of symbolism to approximate Doves being released. Like, that's actually kind of cool that they can come up with something original every time. Yeah, yeah. And you know, my city, my home city that I live in Los Angeles is going to be hosting the 2028 Olympics, which pray for us, please, I really don't want them to do it here. Oh, God. But yeah, I mean, the one thing is like, Los Angeles is the city of entertainment. It's what we do. So I guess if anybody from
天花板上飘落。这就是我们自那以后在所有仪式中避开活鸽子放飞的方式。你知道，尽管这具有重要的象征意义，但我对这样一个想法很感兴趣：每个主办国都必须想出这种全新的象征形式来近似放飞鸽子。就像，每次都能想出原创的东西，这其实挺酷的。是的，是的。你知道，我的城市，我居住的家乡洛杉矶将主办 2028 年奥运会，请为我们祈祷，拜托，我真的不想让他们在这里办。哦，天哪。但是，是的，我的意思是，有一点是，洛杉矶是娱乐之都。这就是我们所做的事情。所以我想如果来自
the LA 2028 committee is listening, try to do something cool for that symbolic dove release. Also, we need more public restrooms before you guys come to Los Angeles. Just think about that too. I mean, that's really what the focus should be. Yeah. 200 white toilets, linings, and sidewalks. Yeah. Oh my god. Dove-shaped public restrooms all dotted around the landscape of Los Angeles. It would be such a service.
洛杉矶 2028 筹委会的任何人正在听，请试着为那个象征性放飞鸽子的环节做点酷炫的事情。另外，在你们来到洛杉矶之前，我们需要更多的公共厕所。也想想这个吧。我的意思是，这才是真正应该关注的重点。是的。200 个白色厕所、内衬和人行道。是的。哦天哪。散布在洛杉矶景观各处的鸽子形状的公共厕所。那将是一项大服务。
Two birds with one stone, Roman, I'm telling you. I know. Well, that's, this is awesome. Thank you so much for telling me about this conundrum that they have to deal with every four years. Thanks, Vivian. After the break, Avery Trevman has a very hot take about the future of the Olympics. We're back with one more story for you from Olympic Games Past and Future. And this one comes to us from articles of interest host and 99% invisible alum, Avery
一石二鸟，罗曼，我跟你说。我知道。好吧，这，太棒了。非常感谢你告诉我他们每四年必须应对的这个难题。谢谢你，维维安。休息之后，埃弗里·特雷夫曼将对奥运会的未来发表一个非常热门的看法。我们带着另一个故事回来，带你了解过去和未来的奥运会。这个故事来自《Articles of Interest》的主持人和 99% invisible 的校友埃弗里·特鲁费尔曼。
Trouffelman. Good to be back. Thank you for having me. Okay, Avery, you're here because you have a big idea about the Olympics, and I would very much like for you to share that idea with us. I have got, I've got, I've got a take that I like to whip out at a certain hour at a party to make people mad. People like to fight me on this, and I really don't understand because I think I'm right. Okay. What's your proposal? Okay. The Olympics should be in Greece every single time.
很高兴回来。谢谢你邀请我。好的，埃弗里，你来到这里是因为你对奥运会有个宏大的想法，我非常希望你能与我们分享这个想法。我有一个，我有一个，我有一个观点，我喜欢在聚会的某个时间点拿出来让大家生气。人们喜欢就这一点跟我争论，我实在不明白，因为我认为我是对的。好吧。你的提议是什么？好吧。奥运会应该每次都在希腊举行。
It should not move to different cities. It should only be in one city. And that city should be in Greece. And I need more people to beat this drum with me. Okay. So tell me, what is behind this proposal? Like, what problem are you trying to solve? Oh, what problem am I not trying to solve? There's so many problems with the Olympics.
它不应该搬到不同的城市。它只能在一个城市举行。那个城市应该在希腊。我需要更多人跟我一起敲响这个鼓。好吧。那么告诉我，这个提议背后的原因是什么？比如，你试图解决什么问题？哦，有什么问题是我没想解决的？奥运会有太多问题了。
And I first had this idea back in 2016 when the Olympics were in Brazil and they were mowing down homes, you know? Like favelas were being destroyed to make way for these big fancy structures that were being erected with like dubious labor practices because it had to be made so quickly. And the thought was just like, well, who is this for?
我第一次有这个想法是在 2016 年，当时奥运会在巴西举行，他们推倒了许多家园，你知道吗？就像贫民窟被摧毁，以便为这些大型豪华建筑让路，这些建筑是在可疑的劳工实践下仓促竖起来的，因为必须如此快速地建造。当时的想法就是，好吧，这到底是为谁建的？
You know, if you're destroying housing so that visitors can come in and then leave. Like who is this actually for? And also it's not like the people in the city want the Olympics to come and change their traffic patterns and change their transit patterns and like disrupt everything. Yeah, yeah.
你知道的，如果你为了让游客进来又离开而摧毁住房的话。这到底是为了谁？而且，城市里的人并不希望奥运会来改变他们的交通模式、改变他们的交通路线并打乱一切。是的，是的。
I mean, it's clear that the Olympics is good for a very select group of regional oligarchs. And it's bad for almost everyone else. I mean, maybe you can get psyched up about it because the Olympics actually, like, you know, it inspires a certain type of, like, pride and like, I love watching Olympics. I know you love watching Olympics. I love the Olympics. I love the Olympics. I propose this because I love the Olympics. But it is extremely disruptive. Yes. watching Olympics. I love the Olympics. I love the Olympics. I propose this because I love the Olympics. But it is extremely disruptive. Well, I mean, I was in Athens, Georgia in grad school
我的意思是，很明显奥运会对一小撮地方寡头是有好处的。但对几乎其他人来说都是坏事。我是说，也许你可能会对它感到兴奋，因为奥运会实际上，就像，你知道的，它激发了某种，就像，自豪感，而且就像，我喜欢看奥运会。我知道你喜欢看奥运会。我喜欢奥运会。我喜欢奥运会。我提出这个是因为我喜欢奥运会。但它极具破坏性。是的。看奥运会。我喜欢奥运会。我喜欢奥运会。我提出这个是因为我喜欢奥运会。但它极具破坏性。好吧，我是说，我在读研究生时在佐治亚州雅典市
during the 96th Atlanta Olympics. Like, when they say an Olympics is in a city, it kind of spreads out. And so a few events, like three or four events, were in Athens, Georgia. And living through it was just misery. And one of the parts that I really didn't like is the local merchants were kind of sold a line
在第96届亚特兰大奥运会期间。就像，当他们说奥运会在某个城市举行时，它会扩散开来。所以一些赛事，比如三四项赛事，是在佐治亚州雅典市举行的。亲身经历它简直就是一场灾难。我真正不喜欢的一个地方是，当地商家被灌输了一套说辞
that they were gonna make tons of money. And it turned out like no one really did. And it just made things kind of miserable because some volunteer in an orange vest told you you couldn't drive down a street that you drove fast every day in your life. And this was in 96, like 9-11 hadn't happened yet. I can't even imagine what it's like today. So they are disruptive. I totally get that. If you live in a city where the Olympics is
说他们会赚大钱。结果却发现根本没人赚到。事情变得一团糟，因为某个穿着橙色背心自愿者告诉你，你不能开车通过一条你每天都开车经过的街道。这是在96年，9·11事件还没发生呢。我简直无法想象今天的状况是怎样的。所以它们具有破坏性。我完全理解这一点。如果你住在正准备申办奥运会的城市
being proposed, I'm telling you, don't buy into it. It's just misery. Get out of town. – Do a house swap. Yeah. And then the other thing, it's terrible for the athletes. Like, why would they want to be uprooted into a totally new city every single time with a totally different climate and like not knowing their way around this job? Being an Olympic athlete, it depends on having slept well and eaten well and like being comfortable. And if it were in the same place every four years
我告诉你，别相信那一套。那纯粹是灾难。离开那儿吧。——换房度假吧。是的。然后还有一件事，这对运动员太糟糕了。我是说，为什么他们每次都要背井离乡到一个完全陌生的城市，去适应完全不同的气候，还对这个地方两眼一抹黑？成为一名奥运会运动员，这有赖于充足的睡眠、健康的饮食以及舒适感。如果每四年都在同一个地方举行
and they could maybe go there to practice in the off season, I think it would do one, especially because the facilities that they erect to house the athletes are like an afterthought after these really fancy stadia. And, you know, I forget which Olympics this was, but the Olympic Village, the athletes were sleeping in cardboard beds. That's insane. Like, it's not treating the actual athletes well,
他们或许可以在休赛期去那里训练，我觉得这会很有用，尤其是因为他们为容纳运动员而搭建的设施，在那些极其奢华的体育场之后简直就像是事后才想起来的附加物。而且，你知道，我忘了这是哪届奥运会了，运动员村里，运动员们竟然睡在纸板床上。这太疯狂了。这简直没有好好对待真正的运动员，
if it's in a different place every time and they're expected to come up with all this housing. Yeah, yeah. I mean, they're also really, really expensive. Like, it's a strange thing to build all these facilities so quickly, and usually it's done with poor labor practices. It's very, very expensive. And, you know, it's done with poor labor practices. It's very, very expensive. And it's really hard for these cities to make their money back
如果每次都在不同的地方，还指望他们自己搞定所有这些住宿的话。对啊，对啊。我是说，它们也真的非常非常贵。就像，这么快就建造所有这些设施是一件很奇怪的事，而且通常伴随着糟糕的劳工规范。它非常非常昂贵。而且，你知道，伴随着糟糕的劳工规范。它非常非常昂贵。而且这些城市很难收回他们的投资
from their investment. And they say it's going to be tourism. But it's not tourism, because as you said, kind of sucks when the Olympics are taking over your city. You know? And if Greece were allowed to invest fully in state of the art facilities, have them maintained, have them used, they could actually make money back.
并靠旅游业回本。但这根本不是旅游业，因为正如你所说，当奥运会接管你的城市时，感觉真是一团糟。你知道吗？如果希腊被允许全力投资最先进的设施，并对它们进行维护和使用，他们其实是能够收回成本的。
Yeah. It's true. They're not in full use after the Olympics. You know, like it's pretty rare for that to happen. And therefore like building one thing, maintaining it, taking care of it, updating it, having the IOC funnel their money into it instead of local taxes being spent on it, taking care of it, updating it, having the IOC funnel their money into it instead of local taxes being spent on it seems like a great idea.
是的。确实如此。奥运会结束后它们并没有被充分利用。你知道的，这种情况发生得相当罕见。因此，建造一样东西，维护它，照料它，更新它，让国际奥委会把钱投入其中，而不是把当地税收花在维护和更新上，听起来像是个绝妙的主意。
I love it. Yes, steady investment and then I think it would allow for other teams from all over the world to just instead of like, oh, we need to update our equipment, just pay for a plane or a train ticket to Greece, you know, like they can have practice there in the off season. It would get full use, like almost constantly. And it would be great for the local economy. People would actually be spending time in whatever city this was. So I don't see why it's so controversial.
我喜欢。是的，稳定的投资，然后我觉得这会让来自世界各地的其他队伍不用再纠结诸如“哦，我们需要更新设备”之类的问题，只需买张去希腊的飞机票或火车票，你知道的，他们可以在休赛期在那里训练。它会得到充分利用，几乎是不间断的。这对当地经济也会大有裨益。人们真的会花时间呆在这个城市的任何地方。所以我搞不懂这为什么会这么有争议。
But what about this tradition of the bidding process? Like there are certain instances where hosting the Olympics is such a proud moment for at least some people in the country. Like the Beijing Olympics, the opening ceremony was just beautiful and artistic and precise. And you could tell that the Chinese government was like, we are going to put our best foot forward to just wow everybody in the world with this.
但申办流程的这个传统又该怎么说呢？比如在某些情况下，举办奥运会让这个国家的至少一部分人感到无比自豪。就像北京奥运会，开幕式既美丽、艺术又精准。你能看出中国政府当时的姿态是：我们要竭尽全力，用这个惊艳全世界的人。
But yeah, I think that's also part of the problem. There's such immense pressure for every host nation to like, quickly, quickly, quickly, clean it up, clean it up. I mean, we did that episode about the 68 Mexico Olympics where a bunch of protesters were shot at. They were protesting the single party government, a totally reasonable grievance, peacefully protesting, and we don't
但话又说回来，我觉得这也是问题所在。每个主办国都承受着巨大的压力，必须快点、快点、快点，把这里打扫干净，打扫干净。我是说，我们做过关于68年墨西哥奥运会的节目，当时有一群抗议者遭到枪击。他们抗议一党制政府，这是一个完全合理的诉求，在进行和平抗议，我们甚至
even know the amount of the dead because they were quickly cleaned up. The blood was washed from the streets so the Olympics could begin. Yes, sure, sometimes it's a great way to harken like arrival on the global scene, but it's also a way for nations to like shove everything quickly under the bed and be like, ta-da, we've made it. And I think a better way to prove yourself in the Olympics is to take care of your athletes and win things. I don't know.
都不知道死者的具体人数，因为他们被迅速清理掉了。街道上的血迹被冲洗干净，好让奥运会得以开幕。没错，当然，有时候这确实是宣告自己登上全球舞台的一种好方法，但它也是各国迅速把一切扫到床底下，然后说“看呐，我们成功了”的一种方式。我觉得在奥运会上证明自己的更好方式是照顾好你的运动员并赢得比赛。我不知道。
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think people think of it as this moment that it can catalyze a lot of infrastructural investments in a place. However, those investments are geared towards this purpose, which is not necessarily serving the public at large. Right, exactly. Like to use the Mexico 68 Olympics again, like that was even a good
对啊。对啊。我是说，我觉得人们认为这是一个契机，可以催化一个地方的大量基础设施投资。然而，这些投资的方向是朝着这个目标服务的，未必能服务于广大公众。没错，完全如此。就像再次以68年墨西哥奥运会为例，那甚至不是一个基础设施建设的良好
example of infrastructure being added. You know, it was like really responsible for the expansion of the Mexico subway system. But still, I mean, it was designed so that no one would have to speak Spanish to understand it. It was like geared for an international audience. And so, like, you know, obviously we're all for new infrastructure, but the whole thing about infrastructure is that it should be for the people who live there, and the Olympics is not for the people who live there. So why Greece? Like, why is that the place that you think it should be the center of all this?
范例。你知道的，它确实推动了墨西哥地铁系统的扩张。但即便如此，我是说，它的设计初衷是为了让人不必会说西班牙语也能看懂。它是面向国际观众量身打造的。所以，就像，你知道的，显然我们都支持新基础设施，但基础设施的全部意义在于它应该为当地居民服务，而奥运会不是为当地居民服务的。那为什么是希腊？就像，为什么你觉得那里应该是这一切的中心？
Anywhere other than Greece would be cultural appropriation. It's Greek, it belongs to Greece. Like, they did the ancient version, they did the revived version. We still, you know, the flame starts in Greece and they run it around the world. It's like so obviously belong, I don't know about the Winter Olympics, that can, maybe that can be a bit every year. But the Summer Olympics.
除了希腊，其他任何地方都是文化挪用。这是希腊的，它属于希腊。你看，他们举办了古代版，他们举办了复兴版。我们仍然，你知道的，圣火从希腊点燃，然后他们把它接力传遍世界。这显然属于——我不知道冬奥会怎么样，也许那可以每年稍微变一变。但夏奥会。
That would be hard to figure out. Yeah, that'd be hard to figure out. But the Summer Olympics 100% belongs in Greece somewhere. I mean, if you think about it, it's like Greece's intellectual property that's being used. And so, yeah, Greece. Also, like why not?
那可能很难搞清楚。是的，那会很难搞清楚。但夏奥会100%属于希腊的某个地方。我是说，如果你仔细想想，这就好像希腊的知识产权正在被使用。所以，对啊，就是希腊。而且，为什么不呢？
It'd be a fun place for athletes to go visit. Like, they'd get to know the restaurants, they'd get to know the whatever, local massage therapists. It would actually be good for the community because there would be more of an incentive to actually get to know it, and it wouldn't feel so temporary. I love it. I think this is a great idea. I'm sold, rather than grabbing onto this, like, new tradition of hosting at a different place every four years,
对运动员来说，去那里访问会是个有趣的地方。他们会了解那里的餐馆，他们会了解各种当地的按摩理疗师。这实际上对社区有益，因为会有更大的动力去真正了解它，而且不会让人觉得那么短暂。我太喜欢了。我觉得这是个绝妙的主意。我被说服了，比起抓住每四年在不同地方举办的这种所谓“新传统”不放，
like embrace the old. The old, I know, I'm like, we must go back to the old ways. But I don't mean it that way. Just be in Greece. Just have it be in Greece. Thank you so much for sharing your thoughts on this. I'm totally sold. I find no flaws in your argument whatsoever at this point.
不如拥抱旧传统。旧传统，我懂，我的意思是，我们必须回到老路上。但我不是那个意思。就定在希腊。就让它在希腊举行。非常感谢你分享对此的看法。我完全被说服了。此刻我在你的论点中找不到任何瑕疵。
Thank you so much. This is very validating. Thank you. Thank you. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Berube, Christopher Johnson, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, and Vivian Ley. Edited by Kelly Prime. Mix and sound design by Martín González. Music by Swan Real. Fact checking by Laura Bolanz. Cathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstedt is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. Nikita Apde is our intern. The rest of the team includes Jason De Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney,
非常感谢。这太有肯定意义了。谢谢。谢谢。本周的《99%无形》由克里斯·贝鲁比（Chris Berube）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado-Medina）和维维安·雷（Vivian Ley）制作。凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）编辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martín González）负责混音和声音设计。天鹅真实乐队（Swan Real）配乐。劳拉·博兰兹（Laura Bolanz）核实事实。凯茜·图（Cathy Tu）是我们的执行制作人。库尔特·科尔施泰特（Kurt Kolstedt）是数字总监。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的资深编辑。尼基塔·阿普德（Nikita Apde）是我们的实习生。团队的其他成员包括杰森·德莱昂（Jason De Leon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney），
Lasha Madon, Nino Potok, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our brand new Discord server. There are over 4,000 people there talking about architecture, talking about Power Broker, talking about all kinds of fun things. Please join us there. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拉沙·马登（Lasha Madon）、尼诺·波托克（Nino Potok）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，总部现在位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市上城区潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们全新的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有4000多人讨论建筑，讨论《权力经纪人》，讨论各种有趣的事情。请加入我们。在99PI.org上有通往该链接以及99PI每一期往期节目的入口。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。